Mientras la observaba hacer esto,
por primera vez en mi vida,
tuve una sensación inestimable:
que podría ser de alguna utilidad a este mundo.
Ese sentimiento fue muy especial,
porque no estoy destinada a ser útil.
En la India rural, las niñas generalmente se consideran sin valor.
Son una responsabilidad o una carga.
Si se consideran útiles,
es solo para cocinar platos, mantener la casa limpia
o criar hijos.
Como segunda hija de mi familia india conservadora,
fue bastante claro desde muy temprana edad.
que nadie esperaba nada de mí.
Estaba condicionada a creer que las tres identidades que me definían,
niña pobre de pueblo,
significaba que tenía que vivir una vida sin voz y sin elección.
Estas tres identidades me obligaron a pensar.
que nunca debí haber nacido.
Sin embargo, era.
A lo largo de mi infancia, mientras rodaba los bidis junto a mi madre,
Me preguntaba:
¿Qué sostendrá mi futuro?
A menudo le preguntaba a mi madre, con mucha ansiedad,
"Amma, ¿mi vida será diferente a la tuya?
¿Tendré la oportunidad de elegir mi vida?
¿Iré a la universidad?".
Y ella respondía,
"Trata de terminar la escuela secundaria primero".
Estoy segura de que mi madre no quiso desanimarme.
Solo quería que yo entendiera
que mis sueños podían ser demasiado grandes para una niña en mi pueblo.
Cuando tenía 13 años, encontré la autobiografía de Helen Keller.
Helen se convirtió en mi inspiración.
Admiré su espíritu indomable.
Quería tener un título universitario como ella,
Así que peleé con mi padre y mis parientes para que me enviaran a la universidad,
y funcionó.
Durante mi último año de licenciatura,
quería desesperadamente escapar de ser obligada a casarme,
Así que mandé una solicitud a un programa de becas en Delhi,
que está a unos 1600 km de mi pueblo.
(Risas)
De hecho, recuerdo que la única forma en que podría llenar la solicitud
sería durante mi viaje a la universidad.
No tuve acceso a las computadoras,
así que tuve que pedir prestado el celular de un joven universitario.
Como mujer, no podían verme con un celular,
así que solía ocultar su teléfono debajo de mi chal
y escribir lo más silenciosamente posible
para asegurarme de que no me escuchaban.
Después de muchas rondas de entrevistas,
entré en el programa de becas con una beca completa.
Mi padre estaba confundido, mi madre estaba preocupada...
(Aplausos)
Mi padre estaba confundido, mi madre estaba preocupada,
pero sentí mariposas en mi estomago
porque iba a salir de mi pueblo
por primera vez
para estudiar en la capital nacional.
De los 97 becarios seleccionados ese año,
yo era la única graduada de una universidad rural.
No había nadie que se pareciera a mí o que hablara como yo.
Me sentí alienada, intimidada y juzgada por muchos.
Un compañero me llamó "Niña coco".
¿Pueden adivinar por qué?
¿Nadie?
Eso es porque me presenté con mucho aceite de coco en el pelo.
(Risas)
Otro me preguntó dónde había aprendido a hablar inglés,
y algunos de mis compañeros prefirieron no tenerme en sus equipos asignados
porque pensaron que no podría contribuir a su discusión.
Sentí que muchos de mis compañeros creían que una persona de la India rural
no podía aportar nada de valor,
sin embargo, la mayoría de la población india es hoy rural.
Me di cuenta de que historias como la mía se consideraban una excepción.
y nunca la expectativa.
Creo que todos nacemos en una realidad que aceptamos ciegamente
hasta que algo nos despierta y se abre un nuevo mundo.
Cuando vi la primera firma de mi madre en su libro de salarios de liadora,
cuando sentí el aire caliente de Delhi en mi cara.
después de un viaje en tren de 50 horas,
cuando finalmente me sentí libre y me dejé ser,
vi un atisbo de ese nuevo mundo que anhelaba,
un mundo donde una chica como yo ya no es una responsabilidad o una carga,
sino una persona útil, una persona de valor
y una persona con dignidad.
Para cuando mi beca terminó, mi vida había cambiado.
No solo había encontrado mi voz perdida,
sino que también tuve la opción de hacerme útil.
Tenía 22.
Regresé a mi pueblo para establecer la Fundación Bodhi Tree,
una institución que apoya a la juventud rural
proporcionándoles educación, habilidades para la vida y oportunidades.
Trabajamos estrechamente con nuestra juventud rural.
para cambiar su vida y beneficiar a nuestras comunidades.
¿Cómo sé que mi institución está funcionando?
Bueno, hace seis meses, teníamos una nueva miembro.
Su nombre es Kaviarasi.
La vi por primera vez en una universidad local en Tirunelveli
durante una de mis sesiones de capacitación.
Como pueden ver, tiene una sonrisa que nunca puedes olvidar.
La guiamos para que pudiera estudiar en la Universidad de Ashoka, Delhi.
Lo mejor de su historia es que ahora está de vuelta en Bodhi Tree como entrenadora
trabajando con dedicación para hacer un cambio en las vidas de otros como ella.
Kaviarasi no quiere sentirse como una excepción.
Quiere ser de utilidad para otros en este mundo.
Recientemente, Kaviarasi fue mentora de Anitha,
que también viene de un pueblo remoto, rural,
vive en una casa de 3 m por 3 m,
sus padres también son campesinos.
Kaviarasi ayudó a Anitha a asegurar la admisión
en un prestigioso programa de pregrado
en una universidad superior en la India con una beca completa.
Cuando los padres de Anitha se mostraron reacios a enviarla tan lejos,
les pedimos a los funcionarios del distrito
hablar con ellos,
Y funcionó.
Y luego está Padma.
Padma y yo fuimos a la universidad juntas.
Ella es la primera en todo su pueblo en graduarse.
Había estado trabajando conmigo en Bodhi Tree.
Hasta que un día decidió ir a la escuela de posgrado.
Le pregunté por qué.
Me dijo que quería asegurarse
de que nunca sería una obligación o una carga para nadie
en ningún momento de su vida.
Padma, Anitha y Kaviarasi
crecieron en las familias y comunidades más duras
que podrían imaginarse.
Sin embargo, el viaje de encontrar mi utilidad en este mundo.
les sirvió para encontrar su utilidad para este mundo.
Por supuesto que hay retos.
Soy consciente de que el cambio no ocurre de la noche a la mañana.
Mucho de mi trabajo implica trabajar con familias y comunidades
para ayudarles a entender por qué lograr una educación
es útil para todos.
La forma más rápida de convencerlos es haciendo.
Cuando ven a sus hijos recibir una verdadera educación,
conseguir un trabajo de verdad, empiezan a cambiar.
El mejor ejemplo es lo que sucedió en mi casa.
Recientemente recibí un premio en reconocimiento a mi trabajo social
por el primer ministro de mi estado.
Eso significaba que iba a estar en la televisión.
(Risas)
Todos estaban conectados a la televisión esa mañana, incluidos mis padres.
Me gustaría creer que al ver a su hija en la televisión.
hizo que mi madre se sintiera útil también.
Con suerte, dejará de presionarme ahora para que me case.
(Risas)
Encontrar mi utilidad me ha ayudado a liberarme de las identidades.
a las que la sociedad me empuja
niña pobre de pueblo.
Encontrar mi utilidad me ha ayudado a liberarme de mi caja,
enjaulada y embotellada.
Encontrar mi uso me ha ayudado a encontrar mi voz,
mi autoestima y mi libertad.
Los dejo con este pensamiento:
¿Dónde te sientes útil a este mundo?
Porque la respuesta a esa pregunta
es donde encontrarás tu voz y tu libertad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)